- Après une nuit de pluiece
est de mise ce matin.
Beaucoup de patience.
Ce conducteur n'a pas bougé
d'un poil depuis plus
d'une heure.
"Depuis le début des inondations
il y a deux semaines, ça prendnd
plus de temps pour se déplacer.
Mais aujourd'hui, c'est pire
encore,"
Même scénario iccénario iccénar.
Il n'y aucune autre option
pour ce camionneurcamionneurcamt
traverser la province.
Les communautés à l'est
très difficiles d'accès.
canadienne est fermée
en raison des inondations.
La seule autre optc'est la rout.
Mais ce matin, il y a eu
un glissement de terrain,
puis un accident de voiture.
est partiellement fermée,
on est bloqué ici depuis
plus de deux heures.la région
est immobilisée, le pasteur
ise Gateway, lui,
s'active.ations,ations,ations,a,
il a transformé son église
e alimentaire.
Depuis, des dizaines de
bénévoles se succèdent
"Nous avons interpellé
res de la communauté
sur Facebook et nous avons reçu
des tonnes de dons
Un élan
qui apaise l'anxiété
des sinistrés comm
Sous un ordre d'évacuation,
la mère de famille a dû
deux semaines et se réfugier
chez de la famille avec
son mari et ses trois enfants.
"C'était angoissant parce qu'on
on n'est plus dans notre maison.
Ils sont émotifs."
Le pasteur est inquiet,
attendue ce soir et ce weekend.t
sans arrêt.
Il souhaite donner un peu
d'aide et d'espoir, en espérant
les pieds au sec. Ici Elisa Ser,
Radio-Canada Abbo